il ya des dizaines et des dizaines de
raisons d'être intersexe et donc du coup
on n'est pas traité de la même façon par
le corps médical ça soit plus ou moins
ou l'intersexuation n'apparaît pas
nécessairement la naissance et à peu se
découvrir à la puberté ou même plus tard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense à l'interdiction des opérations
chirurgicales subies aujourd'hui par des
enfants intersexe et qui sont de plus en
plus largement considérées comme des
mutilations
[Musique]
on n'est pas des poches chose
pathologique des erreurs de la nature on
est comme les autres sauf qu'on a gagné
ni tôt et souvent une identité
différente mais après on est en
on n'est ni plus ni moins normaux ou
anormaux que le reste de la population
[Musique]